[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى
البدايه من باريس التي شهدت احتجاجات
جديده رفضا لقانون تعديل نظام التقاعد
تخللتها صدمات مع الشرطه
[موسيقى]
في واشنطن جدل قانوني سياسي بعد اعلان
رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اليوم
انه سيتم توقيفه ثلاثاء وبعد دعوته انصاره
للاحتجاج
الى اسلام اباد وازمه يختلط فيها سياسي
بالقانوني ايضا حيث مثل رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان امام القضاء
في مواضيع الحصاد
الذكرى التاسعه لضمها الى روسيا بوتين في
القرم لاول مره منذ بدء حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قبل اكثر من عام مسؤول دفاعا
اوكرانيون وامريكيون يناقشون عبر الفيديو
المساعده العسكريه
وفي تطورت الحرب اوكرانيا تقول ان روسيا
شنت سلسله هجمات كثيفه بطائرات مسيره على
مناطق عده وتستهدف الفيف غربا لاول مره
منذ شهور
دون الكشف عن فتره زمنيه تركيا والامم
المتحده تعلنان تمديد اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه كيف تقولون الاتفاقيه
مددت لفتره 120 يوما موسكو تقول انها
ابلغت الاطراف المعنيه بتمديدها لستين
يوما فقط وتتمسك بعدم النظر في تمديد اخر
الا بشروط
على خلفيه ما تعرف بقضيه الاموال الصامته
الى التظاهر بعد ترجيحها ان يتم اعتقاله
ثلاثاء لدى مثوله امام محكمه بنيويورك
وتقارير تتحدث عن عدم التوافق بين القضاء
ومحاميه تسليم نفسه انتقادات من
الجمهوريين المدعي العام في منهتا باساءه
استخدام السلطه ورد من الديمقراطيين لا
احد فوق القانون
[تصفيق]
مشهد متوتر واشتباكات عنيفه بين الشرطه
وانصاره عمران خان يمتثل رسميا لامر حضور
امام محكمه في اسلام اباد
القضاء يلغي اوامر ضبط وتوقيف رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق نتيجه لحضوره
ويقرر تاجيل القضيه لنهايه الشهر الجاري
والشرطه تقتحم منزله في لاهور وتعتقل
عشرات من انصاره
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا ما كشف عنه برنامج الجزيره
التحقيقيه ما خفي اعظم من اسرار ووثائق
الفريق الروسي الذي اعتقل عام 2009 في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في ضوء ما كشفه ما خفي اعظم عن حجم
تدخل موسكو في المشهد السياسي والميداني
ما هو تقييمكم للدور الروسي في ليبيا في
ظل التطورات الحاليه اعتبر نحو 43% من هذا
الدور مازال فاعلا بينما قال قرابه سبعه
وخمسين في المئه ان هذا الدوره تراجع
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوريا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مصادمات بين الامن ومتظاهرين في باريس
خلال احتجاجات رافضه لتعديل نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
قام الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين بزياره
مفاجئه لشبه جزيره القرم في الذكرى
التاسعه لضمها وزار الرئيس الروسي مركزا
للاطفال ومدرسه فيما يبدو انه رد على قرار
المحكمه الجنائيه التي اتهمته بتهريب مئات
الاطفال الاوكرانيين تاتي زياره لتؤكد
الاهميه التي يليها بوتين لشبه جزيره
القرم التي شهدت عده تطورات منذ بدء حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في فبراير شباط من
العام الماضي
يزور رئيس بوتين شبه جزيره القرم في
الذكرى التاسعه لضمها من قبل روسيا هي ارض
روسيه بالنسبه له وبالنسبه للكثير من
الروس الذين يتذكرون استرجاعها في نهايه
القرن الثامن عشر بالنسبه لهم ضموا شبه
جزيره القرم في مارس 2014 مجرد استرجاع
اخر لارض روسيه استفادت موسكو من ثلاثه
عوامل ضم القرم عام 2014 التوتر وعدم
الاستقرار في اوكرانيا بعد ثوره الميدان
والتركيبه السكانيه لشبه الجزيره التي
يشكل الروس اكثر من نصفها ووجود مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي في عاصمتها
بموجب اتفاق سابق مع اوكرانيا ما لوحظ بعد
الضم ان رد الفعل الغربي لم يكن بالحده
التي تعرقل تنفيذ بوسين مخططاته في شبه
الجزيره لتنفيذ هذه المخططات كانت هناك
حاجه ماسه لربط مادي بين القرم وروسيا
فجاء تدشينو جسر كاش عام وثمانيه عشر يبلغ
طول الجسر 19 كلم وهو الاطول في اوروبا
وكلف اربعه مليارات دولار عندما بدات حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في فبراير العمل
الماضي عاد الاهتمام الى شبه جزيره القرم
يقول خبراء عسكريون ان من اهم اسباب هذه
الحرب ضمانه تزويد شبه جزيره القرم
بالمياه من نهر دنيبر جزء من العمليات
العسكريه انطلقت من شبه الجزيره التي توجد
بها عده قواعد عسكريه روسيه بعد اشهر من
بدء الحرب بدات اوكرانيا تستهدف هذه
القواعد وعلى راسها مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي بسيباستوبول ثم جاءت الضربه
الاكبر وهي استهداف جسر كيرش في اكتوبر من
السنه الماضيه كان استهداف الجسر رساله
اوكرانيه رافقها تحول في الموقف السياسي
من القرم في كييف
ففي بدايه الحرب كان الرئيس الاوكراني
يبدي مرونه بشان شبه الجزيره حتى انه
اقترح تاجيل البث في مصيرها 15 عاما لكنه
غير موقفه بعد التحولات التي شهدت المعارك
واخفاق الروس في تحقيق مكاسب كبيره اصبح
زينسكي يطالب باسترجاع القرم وبدا مساعدوه
يتحدثون عن قدره قواتهم على استرجاعها
بقوه السلاح لم يشاطر الغرب حماسته وتسرب
على اللقاءاته مع المسؤولين الامريكيين
انهم دعوه لتقديم مطالب عقلانيه تساعد على
فتح مسار الدبلوماسيه من جديد
فالمقابل قال مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
ان شبه جزيره القرم ارض اوكرانيه
ستستعدها بالدعم الدوري يرماك اضاف في
تغريده لو قبل تسع سنوات استولت القوات
الروسيه على القرم وضمتها بشكل غير قانوني
ومنذ ذلك الحين ذهب ما وصفه بالعدوان
الروسي ابعد من ذلك بكثير واشار الى انه
يجب معاقبه روسيا على ذلك
مستشار نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ومن
موسكو السيده ستانسلاف بترخوفيتش الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه سيد
مارساله الرئيس بوتين في هذا التوقيت من
زياره شبه جزيره القرم
اعتقد ان الرساله واضحه
لجميع من هم في روسيا وفي الخارج ان القرن
هي جزء من روسيا الان وانا روسيا سوف لن
تنسحب منها
تخطط اوكرانيا او مخططات اوكرانيا
لاستعادتها ليست قريبه من الواقع بحسب
بوتين روسيا سوف تحمي القرم من اي اجتياح
اوكراني حتى لو ان الولايات المتحده او اي
دول اخرى لا تزال تدعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
وبتجهيزات ومعدات اخرى اذا المعلومات
بسيطه القرم مختلفه عن خرسان التي
تعتبرها روسيا بموجب الدستور الروسيه جزءا
من روسيا ولكن المقاربه تختلف يريد بوتين
للجميع ان يرى ذلك
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تردد دائما انه لا حل
في اوكرانيا الا بعد استرجاع القرم بحسب
ما تقول الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ولكن هل هذا
محل اجماع من قبل داعمي اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان هذا امر مفهوم دوليا ان القرم هي
ارض اوكرانيا ذاتيهدا ان ضمها في 2014 غير
شرعي ولم يعترف به احد ان هذا استطلاع
الراي او الاستفتاء بالاحرى غير
المشروع لا تعترف به اوكرانيا وبالتالي
روسيا تنتهك
القوانين والقواعد والمواثيق الدوليه وحتى
مدونات السلوك والاخلاق القرم ليست روسيه
هذا امر واضح للجميع هذا الحرب الان
تحصل وتستمر وللاسف ان المفاوضات لم تبدا
فعليا بل توقفت الربيع الماضي ولا يمكن
بسبب موقف الروسي لانها غير مستعده
للتفاوض ولتقبل ان هذا الاجتياح لم ينجح
انه يجب ان تنسحب
بكل سلام وبالتالي تستمر المعارك
ولكن طبعا حين تبدا المفاوضات حين ذاك
يمكننا ان نجد مواقف فتجمع بين الطرفين
ونناقشها لكن الان
روسيا وبشكل فاضح وسافر ترفض التفاوض
وهذا الاجتياح غير المشروع ترفض ان تعترف
انه فشل داريه طيب
طبعا
الجنايه الدوليه اصدرت مذكره لتوقيف
الرئيس بوتين بجرائم حقوق انسان كما تقول
هل يقود هذا
زيارات ربما الرئيس بوتين خارج روسيا
ويقلل من نفوذه في المنطقه بتقديرك
لا انا لا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك اي
تبيعات بارزه لهذا القرار الجميع يفهم ان
هذه القرارات لا قيمه لها كلنا نذكر
الامثله عبر التاريخ عن قاده سياسيين ايضا
تعرضوا للموقف نفسه
واعتبروا ضحايا هذا الجنائيه الدوليه وكان
هناك مذكرات توقيف بحقهم اذكر رئيس
السودان كان في الموقف نفسه ولكن لم يصبه
اي شيء المشكله نفسها مع القذافي ولكن
القذافي يهزم عسكريا بدون هزم عسكري او
هزيمه عسكريه لروسيا سوف لن ينفذ ذلك ولا
يمكن لبوتين ان يخضع للمحاكمه الجميع يجب
ان يذكره انه لا روسيا ولا اوكرانيا ولا
حتى الولايات المتحده تعترف بهذا الجنائيه
الدوليه نعم ربما بعض الدول في اوروبا في
امريكا الجنوبيه ربما في مناطق اخرى
اذا وقعت على
نظام روما ولكن الدول الكبرى النافذه التي
فعلا تؤثر في النظام الدولي امريكا روسيا
الصين لا تعترف الجنائيه الدوليه وايضا
بالنسبه الى روسيا هي غير معنيه لانها لم
تصادق على
نظام روما اوكرانيا ارادت ان تستخدم ذلك
جزئيا ولكن هذا لا اعتقد ان هذا سيوثر على
سلوكيات وتنولا على حركته في السفر خارج
روسيا كيف تنظرون الى زياره الرئيس الصيني
شي جيبينغ الى موسكو مطلع الاسبوع المقبل
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فان
اي زياره او اي محاوله من دوله
عظمى نافذه في العالم ان تضغط في اتجاه
التفاوض والسلام يعتبر اورام مهمه في هذا
السياق اتمنى ان تاتي هذه الزياره ببعض
النتائج ان تقارب روسيا اكثر من طاوله
المفاوضات فهنا مربط الفرس وهنا المشكله
اعتزال عالقه لقد سمعنا مقترحات لاتفاق
سلام من قبل الصين هي معروضه للنقاش وربما
هي ايضا مقبوله بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا لكن
اي بدايه للمفاوضات في هذه المرحله افضل
من لا شيء نامل ان ياتي ذلك ببعض النتائج
وان يغير في موقف روسي ان تعود روسيا
المفاوضات سريعا سيد ستان هذه الزياره
والافكار المطروحه من قبل الجانب الصيني
كيف يمكن ان تتعامل معها موسكو باقتضاب لو
سمحت
الزياره الى
روسيا ليست في عزله من الاسره الدوليه
هي ربما معزوله جزئيه من بعده دول الغربيه
والصين سوف تستثمر في روسيا تستثمر في
علاقتها مع وربما تساعدها عسكريا ايضا
طريقه غير رسميه ربما ببعض الذخائر
هذا يظهر ان قول الغرب ان روسيا معزوله
امر غير صحيح
ايضا سريعا سريعا لو سمحت تحدثت انت ايضا
عن الافكار الصينيه في حال
طرحت افكار لا تتضمن
اقاليم او المناطق التي ضمها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مؤخرا اضافه الى
القرم ماذا سيكون موقف اوكرانيا باقتضاب
لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نناقش المواقف الان
لانها تتشكل عند المفاوضات وفي ميدان
المعارك ايضا وسوف نرى كم من الاراضي يمكن
لجيشنا ان يستعدوا هذا سوف يؤثر على مسار
المفاوضات حاليا على المستوى الدبلوماسي
الاهم هو ان نبدا على الاقل ان تعود روسيا
الى دوله المفاوضات
وان تعمل على حل موضوع الحرب وانهاء
العتيده هذه الطريقه لتوصل الى بناء سلام
هذا اساس جهودنا ولكن المبكر جدا ان نناقش
مواقف محدده على الاقل نبدا نقاشا معينا
او مفاوضات معينه شكرا لك
في موسكو
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
المباحثات التي قادتها بلاده نجحت في
تمديد اتفاقيه الحبوب بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني
المده المقرره والاتفاقيه الحبوب التي
اشرفنا عليها جنبا الى جنب مع الامم
المتحده وكانت من اهم ملفات التسويه التي
تم التوصل اليها منذ الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تنتهي اليوم واود اعلامكم انه
بناء على المحادثات التي اجريناها مع
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني فقد تقرر
تمديد تلك الاتفاقيه ومن المهم الاشاره
الى انه خلال هذه الاتفاقيه عبرت حوالي
800 باخره البحر الاسود ونقلت على متنها
اكثر من 25 مليون طن من الحبوب الى اسواق
العالم
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه انها ابلغت
الاطراف المشاركه في اتفاق الحبوب بتمديده
لستين يوما فقط واضافت انه يمكن تمديده
اذا تم تنفيذه بالكامل بجانبه قال وزير
البنيه التحتيه الاوكراني انه تمديد اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب لمده 120 يوما وكانت الامم
المتحده اعلنت تمديد الاتفاق وحثت جميع
الاطراف على مضاعفه الجهود من اجل تنفيذ
المبادره بالكامل واشارت الامم المتحده
الى نقل نحو 25 مليون طن من الحبوب
والمواد الغذائيه الى 45 دوله خلال
الفترتين الاوليين وهو مساهم في خفض اسعار
الغذاء عالميا وتحقيق الاستقرار في
الاسواق
وتهدف مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود الى التي
توسطت فيها الامم المتحده وتركيا بين
روسيا واوكرانيا في يوليو الماضي الى
السماح باعاده تصدير الحبوب بعدما عرقلت
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا الانتاج والتسويق
وهو ما ادخل قبل اشهر بل ادخل قبل اشهر
اضطرابا في الاسواق العالميه ومخاوف من
ارتفاع الاسعار بعد انقطاع ما يعرف بسلاسل
التوريد ابرز نقاط مبادره الحبوب في العرض
التالي
اتفاقه تصدير الحبوب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
برعايه الامم المتحده يسمح بتصديرها عبر
موانئ اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
يوجد نحو 25 مليون طن من الحبوب على الاقل
عالقه في موانئ اوكرانيا
سيجري التصدير عن طريق ثلاثه موانئ هي
اوديسا نشورنو
ستسير السفن عبر البحر الاسود برعايه
امميه لتصل لاحقا الى مضيق البوسفور
في حين سيكون هناك مركز لتنسيق الصادرات
في اسطنبول يضم كلا من اوكرانيا وروسيا
وتركيا والامم المتحده
وتستكمل السفن طريقها الى بقيه دول العالم
لا تنص الاتفاقيه على وجود حراسه عسكريه
لسفن الشحن كما لن تزال الالغام البحريه
ومن المتوقع ان تبدا سفن شحن الحبوب في
تسيير رحلتها في غضون اسبوع
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه ان الادعاء
العام في منهجه لم يتوافق مع محامي ترامب
على تاريخ لتسليم نفسه وفي سياق ذاته ذكرت
شبكه سي بي اس عن مسؤولين امنيين ان
الاستعدادات تجاريه لاحتمال توجيه اتهامات
جنائيه الاسبوع المقبل في مقاله شبكه
بلومبرج ان هذه الاستعدادات شملت دعوه
وكالات انفاذ القانون بما في ذلك الخدمه
السريه ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
للاجتماع في وقت مبكر من الاسبوع المقبل
للتخطيط الامني في حاله تم توجيه الاتهام
لترامب ويواجه ترامب الذي اعلن توقع
اعتقاله بدايه الاسبوع المقبل عددا من
القضايا والتحقيقات نستعرض بعضها في هذا
التقرير
مع اقتراب سخونه الموسم الانتخابي الطويل
في الولايات المتحده تلوح في الافق متاعب
قانونيه تواجه الرئيس السابق والباحثه عن
ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري لمنصب الرئيس دونالد
ترامب على صفحته في موقع التروث الذي
التحق به بعد ان صدته مواقع التواصل
الشهيره اعلنت ترامب انه يتوقع اعتقال
قوات الامن له الثلاثاء المقبل مستغيثا
بالمتعاطفين معه للخروج والتظاهر نصره له
لم يصدر عن الجهاد القضائيه الامريكيه
تاكيد رسمي لكن وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
التي تتابع دقائق التحقيقات في سلوك ترامب
وما اكثرها تتحدث عن قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه
لاسكات عارضه كانت على علاقه بترامب في
مخالفه لقانون تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
وقانون السجلات الضرائب اعتقال ترامب ان
حدث قد تكون له تداعيات سياسيه ضخمه
بالنظر الى سيطرته على كتله معتبره في
الحزب الجمهوري وقد دعاها لدعمه مع ما
يعنيه هذا من عوده الاحتقان شارع الامريكي
لكن الاعتقال المفترض قد لا يؤثر على حظوظ
ترامب الانتخابيه بل يقول محامي الرئيس
السابق ان الاعتقال قد يقنع فئه من
الامريكيين ان الدوله العميقه تمعن في
اضطهاده وقانونيا لا تمنع النصوص المعتمده
في الولايات المتحده السجناء من الترشح بل
واداره البلاد من الزنزانه في حال فوزه في
الانتخابات ويواجه ترامب الطامح للعوده
الى البيت الابيض في خريف العام المقبل
رئيسا للولايات المتحده جمله من التحقيقات
منها ما هو مدني ومنها ما هو جنائي واخرى
تتعلق بالامن القومي ابرز القضايا المدنيه
ما تحقق فيه ولايه نيويورك وهو شبهه تقليل
ممتلكاته وتضخيم نفقاته لاسباب تتعلق
بالتهرب الضريبي والقيام بالعكس الاقتراض
الاموال من البنوك اما السلطات التحقيق في
ولايه جورجيا فتنظر في مزاعم محاوله ترامب
وحلفائه التدخل في نتائج انتخابات سنه
وفيدراليا يحقق مكتب التحقيقات الاف بي اي
في اداره ترامب للوثائق السريه التي كانت
في عهدته اثناء ممارسه مهامه وسبق لفريق
من المكتب ان اغار على مقر اقامته في
مارلاجو فلوريدا حيث استعاد عشرات الوثائق
عدد منها على اعلى درجات سريه وبعضها
يحتوي اسرار النوويه وكل هذه التحقيقات
مستمره خلف الستار ولم يتكشف من تفاصيلها
سوى القليل
[موسيقى]
لنفهم اكثر عن الموضوع
المحامي بروست دولفال المختص في القانون
الدستوري السيد بروس ما وجاهت اعتقال
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على خلفيه
التهم الجنائيه الموجهه اليه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه في الحقيقه هذا
لم يحصل
لم يتم
توقيف اي رئيس سابق على اساسي سلوكيات
جرميه في العام 73 كاد يحصل ذلك حين قال
الرئيس انه صوته وجه اليه لوائح اتهام
والرئيس فورد قد سامحه عفا عنه ولكن هذا
امر غير مسبوق وهو مزعج جدا مقلق جدا
واتمنى ان يتوقف الموضوع عند هذا الحد
يبدو ان هذا ما ردوه ملاحقه سياسيه
وبالاضافه الى انها قضايا من الصعب ان
تثبت عليه وبالتالي هذا امر غير مسبوق
ونحن ندخل معتركا مجهولا الديمقراطيون
يقولون انه لا احد فوق القانون
ما الذي يجعلكم
متاكدين الى هذه الدرجه توقيفه لن يتم
لانه هو قال بانه سيتم توقيفه يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل
انا لا اشكك في انه سوف يتم اعتقاله
ولكنني اعتقد انه فعلا ربما يعتقل ولكن
طبعا لا احد فوق القانون ولكن
سيكون توجها او منحا مقلقا اذا كان هناك
نواب عمون من المقاطعات في انحائي
الولايات المتحده يمكنهم ان يوقفوا رئيسا
سابقا انه منحى انه توجه مقلق طبعا
هو ليس ممنوعا او محظورا في الدستور ولكن
لم نعتده كممارسه فعاليه اعتقد ان هذه
المحاكمه بالتحديد في مانعات حول موضوع
الشابه
ليست قضيه قويه متماسكه فهي تجمع بين
مفهومين متضادين وفي نهايه المطاف انا لست
متاكدا ان هناك فعلا جريمه قد حصلت
هناك نقطه مهمه في حال تم التوقيف في حال
تم توقيفه كما يقول على الاقل الرئيس
ترامب ما الذي سيحصل سيتم اخذ بصماته
وبياناته ويفرج عنه بكفاله سيتم توقيفه
لفتره طويله هل لك ان تشرح لنا السيناريو
وما الخيارات امام الرئيس السابق لمواجهه
هذا التوقيف في حال كان سيحصل فعليا
يجب ان نرى ما هي لائحه الاتهام لا احد
يعرف محتواها ما هي القطع الموجهده ضده
اذا صدرت لائحه الاتهام سوف يعتقل او يتم
ايقافه بالاحرى وعاده هناك اجراء تعاوني
حيث ان الشخص موضوع لائحه الاتهام
والطوعيا يسلم نفسه ويمثل امام المدعي
العام او الى مكتب المدعي امام القادم مع
محامي وانا اتمنى
ان لا يتم توقيفه بوضع الاصوات في يديه لا
يصير ذلك سير كان اعلاميا الافضل هو ان
ياتي هو طمعان لكي يتم توقيف نعم تؤخذ
بصماته نعم تؤخذ بياناته وصورته وتوجه ضده
تهم ما يحصل بعد ذلك اما يمثل بصوره
اساسيه حيث يدخل في اتفاق او يكون هناك
فتره
توقيف حيث يقرروا اذا كان سوف
يعترفوا بذنبه او يقول انه باري سوف يكون
هناك عدد من الحالات اذا قبلت القضيه في
المحكمه ام لا وثم يتم اتخاذ قرار اما
يحاكم امامه هيئه محلفين ام لا ربما يكون
هناك احتمال للافراج عنه مقابل مبلغ مالي
ولكن من قبل هذا لم يحصل
تقرر المحكمه اذا كانت سوف تلقيه في
البلاد او يمكن ان تبقيه مجرونا ام لا
كلها المحامي بروست في ميريلاند
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل الجزيره ان رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان غادر المجمع
القضائي في العاصمه بعد اثبات حضوره امام
المحكمه في القضيه الخاصه بالتصرف في
هدايا ثمينه وتوجه الى منزله في لاهور بعد
تاجيل القضيه الى الثلاثين من الشهر
الجاري وقال مراسل الجزيره ان مواجهات
كانت اندلعت بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين مؤيدين
رئيس وزراء الباكستاني السابق في محيط
المجمع القضائي في العاصمه ان الشرطه
استخدمت قنابل الغاز المسيل الدموع لتفريق
المتظاهرين الذين ردوا برشق الشرطه
بالحجاره
بيت المجمع القضائي في العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد وقد اصبح ساحه
للمواجهات بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين من مؤيدي
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
المواجهات اندلعت مع وصول عمران خان الى
المحكمه للمثور امام القضاء في تهمه تتعلق
ببيعه هدايا ثمينه ابانه توليه منصبه
اطلق رجال الشرطه للتو الغاز المسيله
للدموع باتجاهنا وتعاملوا معنا بعنف اثناء
تقدمنا صوب المحكمه وبداوا بعد ذلك بضربنا
بالحروات انظر هذه اثار الهراوه الصابون
بجرح في راسي
ومع بدء المداولات الغل القاضي مذكره
اعتقال خان وارجا الجلسه الى الثلاثين من
مارس الحالي ليعود خان بعدها برفقه انصاره
مره اخرى الى لاهور تطورات دفعت رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني شهبا الشريف الى وصف
تصرفات عمران خان بالغريبه واتهمه
باستخدام الشعب دروعا بشريه وبالقاء
انصاره القنابل الحارقه على الشرطه لم يكن
محيط المجمع القضائي هنا في العاصمه اسلام
اباد ساحه المواجهات الوحيده بين الشرطه
ومؤيدي عمران خان بل امتدت ايضا لتشمل
محيط منزل عمران خان في محكله بمدينه
لاهور
بعد مغادره عمران خان منزله متوجعا الى
اسلام اباد اقتحم مئات من عناصر الشرطه
المنزل مبررين ذلك بتعرضهم لاطلاق نار وهو
ما نفته عائله خان
في البدايه قالت الشرطه انهم سيرفعون
المخلفات الموجوده في محيط البيت ثم
احضروا اليه ثقيله وفجاه بداوا يدفعون
البوابه وعندها اعترضنا وطلبنا اظهارا
مذكره التفتيش ولم تكن هنالك قوه من
الشرطه النسائيه فقط الشرطه وفرقه مكافحه
الشغب
[موسيقى]
الشرطه قالت انها صادرت اسلحه وذخائر من
منزل خان واعتقلت عددا من انصاره قبل ان
تنسحب منه لاحقا وهو ما نفته العائله ايضا
سمير النمر الجزيره اسلام اباد
نبقى في اسلام اباد تنضم الينا السيده ناز
بلوش النائبه في البرلمان الباكستاني عن
حزب الشعب المشارك في الحكومه سيده ناس
اكثر من 95 قضيه رفعت ضد خان منذ اقصائه
عن السلطه الا يمكن اعتبار هذا بانه
محاوله لابعاده عن المشهد السياسي كما
يقول هو وانصاره بطبيعه الحال
[موسيقى]
بدا اود ان اقول ان رئيس الوزراء السابق
رضي بعدد من الاستثناءات بالنسبه او
الاعفاءات عفوا بالنسبه الى القضايا التي
وجهت ضده لان عدد القضايا التي رفع ضده
حول مسائل مختلفه مثلا بيع هدايا دوله
قدمت الى
دوله باكستان وقام ببيعها كلها قضايا
يواجهها في المحكمه هناك عدد كبير من
القضايا التي وجهت اتهامات له عود ضده
فيها يجب او هو حاول ان يقاوم الاستدعاء
الى المحكمه وبالتالي وجب على الشرطه اكثر
من مره ان تتوجه اليه هو ان تاتي به ليمثل
امام المحكمه ولكن بسبب العنف الذي حصل
بسبب الحشود وبسبب انصاره
هناك عدد من الاشخاص قاموا بالتخريب قاموا
بتدمير الممتلكات العامه بسيارات
لانهم لانهم غير مقتنعين بان السيدنات اذا
سمحت لي لانهم غير مقتنعين بان هذه
الاتهامات الموجهه لعمران
خان هي اتهامات جنائيه هم يقولون وهو يقول
بان هناك مؤامره سياسيه لابعاده عن المشهد
السياسي مستقبلا كيف تفهمون هذا الكلام من
عمران خان
لا ليس هناك شيء من هذا القبيل اطلاقا
عمران خان هو الذي قام بحل حكومته في
برينجا هو الذي حل
حكومته في مقاطعات
كيفي
وبالنسبه الى اللجنه الانتخابيه في
باكستان تحضر لدى الانتخابات وهناك مجال
لكافه الاحزاب المشاركه فيها ليس هناك سبب
يدعه للقول انه فعلا يتم ابعاده عن المشهد
السياسي
اعتقد ان هناك مئات القضايا التي تواجهها
الكثير من الاحزاب واعطائها ولكن نحترم
حكم القانون ونطلب منه ذلك
حكم قانون لدينا دوله قانون نشرك معنا
السيده مليحه هاشمي عضو اللجنه الاعلاميه
لحزب انصاف بزعامه عمران خانه الضم الينا
من اسلام اباد سيده مليحه السيده ناز بلوش
تقول لماذا لا يتم الاحتكام للقضاء وتسال
لماذا يستخدم دائما السيد عمران خان
انصاره في مواجهه المحكمه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه
في كل مرض
ظهر فيها عمران خان امام المحكمه اتى
الناس طوعا لكي يدعموا لانهم ارادوا ان
يظهروا تعاونهم ودعمهم له فعلا الناس من
صميم قلبهم يؤمنون بانه بريء
[موسيقى]
كل القضايا وكل الاتهامات
الخاطئه التي وجهت ضده بالسرقه والفساد
والى ما هنالك حتى على شعبه هل تتخيلون ان
احد العاملين في حزب سياسي قد تم تعذيبه
ومن ثم قتل بدم بارد حتى
تهمه قتله وجعت الى عمران خان وبالتالي
هذا شيء يرفض الناس ان يصدقوه وهو من صميم
قلبهم يؤمنون بانه صادق لانه بريء
هذا الضغط الحكومه تسال لماذا لا يتم يعني
لماذا لا يتم مواجهه هذه القضايا بالمحكمه
وابراز براءه السيد عمران خان كما تقولين
وهو اليوم مثل امام المحكمه وخرج وعاد الى
منزله في لاهور وتم تاجيل هذه المسائله
لماذا اللجوء الى الشارع دائما
والاستقواء بانصاره
نعم هل يمكن ان ندع السؤال لو اكثر هو
اليوم خضع خضع للاستجواب وخرج من المحكمه
وعاد الى منزله بلاهور اذا لماذا لا تترك
الامور
للقضاء ولاجراء محاكمه بعيدا عن هذه
التوترات في الشارع
في الحقيقه
هو كان يجيب على كافه
الطلبات القضائيه يستوفي المتطلبات
القضائيه وما تطلب المحكمه بكل سعاده
بعكسي اخصامه السياسيين العالم كله شهد
كيف تعرض
لمحاوله قتل منذ خمسه اشهر اشهر في وزيره
بعد في باكستان مع انه
كان بصحه سيئه وتعرض
لثلاثه طلقات كان يحضر الى المحكمه
سياسيه
لتوجهت ضدهم اذا بالرغم من ذلك يظهر اقصى
احترام للمحكمه ويحضر الجلسه اما بالنسبه
الى دعم الشعب الباكستاني له في منزلي
هذا خيار ماذا حريتهم اذا ارادوا التضامن
عمران خان هذا يعود لهم اذا ارادوا ان
يعربوا عن اشياءهم تجاه الاحزاب السياسيه
الاخرى هو لا يطلب منهم شيئا
السؤال الاخير للسيده ناز
شكرا سيده مليحه سؤال اخي للسيده ناس
السيده ناس ذكرت السيده مليحه محاوله
اغتيال عمران خان قبل اشهر حزب انصاف يقول
بان الحكومه خسرت كل الانتخابات الفرعيه
التي اجريت منذ تولي الحكومه الجديده
السلطه بالتالي ما الذي يطمئن عمران خان
بان ما يحصل الان هو ليست محاوله لابعاده
عن السلطه باقتضاب لو سمحتي
اولا اود ان اوضح وان اصحح بالقول ان
عمران خان
لم يفز بكافه الانتخابات له ولا حزبه لان
الانتخابات التي اقيمت في مقاطعه سان في
كراتشي وحيدر اباد
ايضا كان حزبه في المرتبه الثالثه ولا حتى
في المرتبه الاولى ولا الثانيه اذا جاء في
المرتبه الثالثه من حيث عدد المقاعد اذا
خسر هذه الانتخابات والمقاعد المحليه في
مقاطعه سن لاسيما مدينه كراتشي حيث عدد
الناخبين كبير وفاز بعدد كبير في 2018
بالاضافه لانتخابات الفرعيه في مقاطعه سن
في كاراكشي خسر المقاعد
شكرا السيده السيده ناس فقد الاشاره انا
لم اقل بانه فاز بل قلت بان الائتلاف
الحكومي خسر الانتخابات الفرعيه شكرا لكما
السيده ناز بلوش في اسلام اباد والسيده
مليحه هاشمي ايضا في اسلام اباد
[موسيقى]
في مزيد من الاخبار حول العالم قال سامح
شكري وزير الخريجات المصريه ان هناك رغبه
في تطوير العلاقات مع تركيا واستعاده
زخمها على كل المستويات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه شكري اضافه في مؤتمر صحفي مع
نظير التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو في القاهره
ان بلاده تتطلع لفتح قنوات التواصل بين
الاجهزه الحكوميه في البلدين
ان شاء الله
الاستمرار التواصل والتنظيف مع معالي
الوزير ايضا فتح قنوات التواصل فيما بين
الاجهزه الحكوميه
واستمرار عملنا بشكل كثيف حتى نصل الى ما
نتطلع اليه سويا من
استعاده هذه العلاقه الهامه تحدثنا
بما هو الخطوه
التي تؤدي يؤدي اليها هذا المسار وتكون
مؤشر
لتناولنا الكافه القضايا
وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود تشاوش اوغلو
بدوره قال انه بحث مع نظيره المصري سامح
شكري مساله اعاده السفراء من جديد بين
البلدين واكد تشاوش اوغلو خلال زياره
للقاهره هي الاولى لوزير تركي منذ عشر
سنوات انه على يقين من ان العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مصر سترفع الى اعلى مستوى
في اقرب فرصه ممكنه
بحثت مع اخي سامح شكري مساله اعاده
السفرائي للبلدين من جديد وما يمكننا فعله
بشان هذا الموضوع في المستقبل القريب
اضافه الى تقييم العلاقات والخطوات التي
من الواجب اتخاذها انا على يقين انه في
اقرب فرصه ممكنه سنقوم برفع علاقاتنا
الدبلوماسيه الى اعلى مستوى ممكن
الى شرق اسيا ونقطه توتر اخرى متجدده هناك
حيث وصف وزير الخارجيه الهندي سوبرا مينام
جاي شانك نار الوضع على الحدود بين بلاده
والصين في منطقه لدى غربيه جبال الهملايا
بانه هش وخطير واضاف الوزير الهندي ان
قوات البلدين تنتشر بالقرب من بعضها البعض
في المنطقه الحدوديه وقال ان العلاقات
الهنديه الصينيه لا يمكن ان تعود الى
طبيعتها حتى يتم حل الخلاف الحدودي وفقا
للاتفاق الموقع في سبتمبر عام 2020 الذي
توصل اليه مع نظيره الصيني واندلعت اعمال
العنف في القطاع الشرقي من الحدود غير
المرسمه بين البلدين في سبتمبر الماضي ولم
تسفر عند ضحايا يذكر ان اربعه وعشرين
جنديا قتلوا في اشتباكات بين الجانبين
منتصف عام 2020 قبل ان تنجح محادثات
دبلوماسيه وعسكريه في تهدئه الاوضاع
بعد قليل في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
ما يسمى بصراع العملاقين على تخوم
الهملايا ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن دلالات
التحذير الهندي وتوقيته
[موسيقى]
خرجت مظاهراته ليليه في شوارع العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس تخللتها مصادمه بين الشرطه
واعداد من المحتاجين وذلك استمرارا
للمظاهرات ضد قانون التقاعد الذي مررته
الرئاسه الفرنسيه دون المرور عبر تصويت
برلماني ويرفض المحتجون وورائهم النقابات
الفرنسيه
بندا يقضي برفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
ودعت النقابه العامه للشغل في فرنسا الى
مزيد من تصعيد الاحتجاجات حتى الخميس
المقبل فيما دعت احزاب معارضه لسحب الثقه
من الحكومه الفرنسيه
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل وجها لوجه مع
ازمه سياسيه بالغه التعقيد بعد تمرير
حكومته قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد من دون
تصويت الجمعيه الوطنيه
ماكرون تجاوز الغضب الاجتماعي العالم الذي
يعم المدن الفرنسيه وقرر استنادا على
الماده
49.3 من الدستور تمرير القانون الذي ينص
بنده الرئيسي على رفع سن التقاعد من 62
عاما الى 64
ورغم ان الرئيس الفرنسي يقول ان القانون
جاء استجابه للتدهور المالي الذي تشهده
صناديق التقاعد ولشيخوخه السكان فان
الشارع النقابي ومعارضيه يرون في الخطوه
نكسه له وانه رهن رصيده السياسي بتمريره
هذا القانون
تواصلت المظاهرات الرافضه للقانون في
مختلف المدن الفرنسيه وبينها باريس وفرقت
الشرطه التجمع في ساحه الكونكورد القريب
من الجمعيه الوطنيه وقصر الاليزيه وكانت
قد شهدت الليله الماضيه اشتباكات ومصادمات
بين المحتجين وقوات الامن وجرع اعتقال
عشرات الاشخاص حسب اعلان وزاره الداخليه
واتخذت الشرطه اجراءات امنيه مكثفه مع
تجدد الاحتياجات واتساع رقعتها ودعوه
النقابات الى تجمعات محليه يومي السبت
والاحد وتكثيف التظاهر ليصل الذروه يوم
الخميس في هذه الاثناء تسعى عدد من احزاب
المعارضه للتصويت في الجمعيه الوطنيه
لصالح اقتراحات بسحب الثقه من حكومه
اليزابيث بورن وتظاهر منتسب الحزب اليمين
المتطرف الوطنيون في باريس مطالبين
الجمعيه الوطنيه بالتصويت لصالح حجب الثقه
عندما يتم ذلك يوم الاثنين كما هو مرجح
حركه الاضرابات الشامله والاحتياجات
الواسعه على قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
تنتظم فرنسا منذ السابع من هذا الشهر
وشارك فيها مئات الالاف ومنذ التاسع عشر
من يناير الماضي تظاهر الفرنسيون في ثمان
مناسبات رفضا للقانون
وعدت مجمل الاضرابات الى تعطل حركه النقل
واغلاق بعض المدارس وتكدس النفايات وتوقف
شاحنات الوقود بالاضافه لتاثر حركه النقل
بين فرنسا وعدد من الدول حيث الغيت عشرات
الرحلات البحريه والجويه ورحلات القطارات
[موسيقى]
نعود الى تحذير وزير الخارجيه الهندي من
ان الوضع مع الصين هشه وخطير على جبهه في
منطقه الهملايا حديث الوزير الهندي يتعلق
تحديدا بموقع حدودي محل نزاع في منطقه
حيث كانت قوات هنديه وصينيه تقفان وجها
لوجها تقع هذه المنطقه على ارتفاع نحو
4000 متر في منطقه جبليه نائيه تتميز
بانهارها سريعه الجريان عند الطرف الشمالي
للهند التقطوا لداخ ملاصقه لهضبه اكثر
التي تطالب بها الهند وتعتقد باحقيتها
فيها لكنها تخضع لاداره الصين تشترك الهند
والصين في حدود طولها
3500 كيلومتر وتدور النزاعات في نقاط عده
من بينها
وهو ممر استراتيجي يربط بغرب الصين وبجوار
وادي جالوان ومنطقه ناكولا في اقصى الشرق
يطالب كلا الجانبين باحقيته في مساحات
شاسعه من اراضي الطرف الاخر على امتداد
الحدود في منطقه الهيمالايا وترجع جذور
بعض الخلافات الى عمليات ترسيم الحدود بان
عهد الاستعمار البريطاني في الهند
خطط الهند والصين عام
1962 حربا حدوديه قصيره لكنها كانت دمويه
وادى ارتياب كل طرف في الاخر في الاخر الى
تفجر الوضع اكثر من مره منذ ذلك الحين فقط
قتل اربعه وعشرون جنديا على الاقل في
اشتباكات بين الجانبين في المنطقه منتصف
عام 2020 لكن جولات من المحادثات
الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه هدات الوضحه وحتى
قبل اشتباكات يونيو 2020 كانت الهند قد
بدات تتجه استراتيجيا الى الغرب لتعميق
التعاون الامني مع الولايات المتحده
واليابان واستراليا ومنطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ
مواجهه اخرى بين قوات هنديه وقوات انسانيه
وقعت في الاسبوع الاخير من نوفمبر توشين
الثاني الماضي في منطقه دمشوك في لدخ شمال
غربي البلاد بالقربه من مكاني مواجهات
يونيو عام 2020 وفي ديسمبر من العام
الماضي وقعت اشتباكات بين الجيشين الصيني
والهنديه على الحدود المتنازه عليها في
منطقه الهملايا واسفرت عن اصابه جنود من
الطرفين وفي كثير من الاحيان يقال ان
السبب في ازدياد التوتر واعمال البناء في
مجال البنيه التحتيه قرب مناطق موضع موضع
نزاع او عليها على كل حال لنفهم اكثر هذا
الصراع هناك ينضم الينا من اوكسفورد
الدكتور ادوارد هاويل استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه المختص بشؤون شرق اسيا بجامعه
اوكسفورد نعم هي منطقه توتر كما تبعنا في
العرض السابق ولكن كيف تفهم توقيت التحذير
الهندي للصين من ان الوضع على الجباش
شكرا على الاستضافه واضح انها قضيه مستمره
وذلك منذ 60 عاما من النزاع على الحدود
وقد اشتعلت مره اخرى السنه الماضيه
بالنسبه الى موروث العامه 62 الذي هزمت
فيه الهند فياتي هذا التوقيت الان
ليكون مهما حيث ان
الهند كانت بمثابه ينظر اليها مما ثابت
وسيط بين الغرب واوكرانيا حتى وزير
الخارجي الهندي مؤخرا اوضح انه امامها
القديمه مسار طويل ايضا لدينا مساله
العلاقات بين الدولتين التي هي في تراجع
لاصقه في العقد الاخير مع وقوف الهند ضد
مبادرات طريق الحرير الخاصه بالصين بالنظر
الى علاقات
الصين الاقتصاديه وغيرها باكستان هناك
الكثير من الاسئله المطروحه حول السياسه
الخارجه الهنديه الصينيه وايضا انعدام
الاستقرار بشكل اوسع للنظام العالمي الذي
نواجهه الان ما احتماليه اندلاع مواجهه
اوسع ربما دكتور عن سابقاتها في هذه
الجبهه بين الصين والهند
بالنسبه الى هذه المواجهات الطفيفه هو
مساله السياده والسيطره على الاراضي وهي
قد جلمت حل منذ ثلاثه اعوام لدينا منطقه
التي تقول الصين انها جزء من تشينجان
الخاصه بها
ولدينا الهند في مواجهه ذلك التي
تقول
هي لها وتعود لها مع انها تحت اداره صينيه
اذا ما نشهده هو هذه المواجهات المستمره
التي نتوقع ان تستمر ايضا وهذا النزاع
ان يستمر لاسيما مع التنافس بين الدولتين
فيما يتعلق بالحدود طول هذا الحدود
واي جوانب واي قوانين يمكن الاستناد عليها
لاسيما
اننا نرى الهند تدعم ادعاءاتها بناء على
خط العام 1914 وهذا مطرف اصيل الاعتراف
بها وبالتالي يكون البلدان في مواجهه او
بدون اتفاق دكتور الصين تواجه طبعا ضغوطات
غربيه فيما يتعلق بتايوان وايضا ضغوطات
اخرى فيما يتعلق بما يقول الغرب
مساعدات صينيه
لروسيا امام كل هذا
كيف او كيف ترى سياق تعامل الصين مع هذه
القضيه الشائكه على الحدود مع الهند
من الواضح ان هناك الكثير من القضايا
العالقه والشرائكه في السياسه الخارجيه
الصينيه حيث يصعب على الحكومه الصينيه ان
ترتب اولوياتها طبعا الاهم بالنسبه اليها
وبالقرب منها هي مساله تايوان ولكن كما
اسلفتم لدينا الصين وروسيا
تقتربان اكثر
وتوطدان العلاقات لدينا العلاقات مع كوريا
التي لم تكن يوما جيده ولدينا هذا النزاع
مع الهند الذي يبدو انه سوف يستمر في
المستقبل
لان اي حل لهذا النزاع حاليا بين الهند
والصين تبدو لي مستبعده شكرا الدكتور
ادوارد هاول في جامعه اوكسفورد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
نقص خطر جديد حول ممارسات البشر وتاثيرها
على البيئه تتسبب انشطه استغلال الغابات
والحرائق والزراعه بزوال غابات الجبال
بوتيره متسارعه على ما اظهر دراسه حديثه
تحذر من تفاقم الوضع في هذه المناطق
الحيويه في العالم وقد غطت الغابات
الجبليه مليار ومئه مليون هكتار من مساحات
الكوكب في عام 2000 بحسب معدي دراسه نشرت
نتائجها في مجله
لكن ما لا يقل عن 78 مليونا ومئه الف
هكتار زال بين عامي 2000 و 2018 بحسب
خلاصات توصل اليها الباحثون باستخدام
بيانات الاقمار الصناعيه تعد الجبال موطنا
لخمسه من الطيور والثدييات والبرمائيات في
العالم خاصه في الغابات ما يجعل فقدانها
ينذر بالخطر على التنوع البيولوجي
نهايه الحصاد شكرا للمتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]